c'est un fait dans de nombreuses régions
de france le couvre-feu ne semble plus
être une arme suffisantes pour lutter
contre la propagation de lakovic 19 et
de ces variants des alpes-maritimes
dunkerque le pas de calais de plus en
plus de régions de france confie le
week-end pour stopper la propagation de
l'épidémie pourtant une région dont les
nids en réanimation sont presque saturé
ne connaît pas le même sort
il s'agit de l'île de france en effet
jusqu'à maintenant cette région semble
être protégés contre la menace d'un
recours finement le week-end
le gouvernement justifie ce traitement
de faveur par plusieurs facteurs
notamment le coût que cela pourrait
avoir en termes de dégâts psychologiques
mentaux et sociaux il faut dire que
paris est la ville où les habitants
vivent dans les plus petites surfaces en
france toutefois le premier ministre
prévient que cette situation pourrait
changer
on me suivant au jour le jour cette
situation pourrait nous tenir prêts à
tout moment à prendre les mesures que
celles ci appelle alors faut-il qu'on
finit l'île de france et ça y est ils
sont là ils nous ont rejoint faute
sécurité gilles de france à thiaw laye à
yoann habitants de calais qui est déjà
énervé mononoke j'aime beaucoup il le
sait alors nous savons très bien la
république on m'a juste devant bochum
alors elle et elle est jolie et elle et
elle est intelligente joly c'est rien
belle porte parole de la république en
marche en tout cas elle parvient la
parole de son mouvement
enfin et de voilà de son parti comment
ça va mode ça va être quoi sert il
battre
[Applaudissements]
des toiles il ya des affinités par tous
comme un tabou toi comment je t'embrasse
et ouais on est resté deux ans
je suis déjà venu pour les gêner journée
je sais mon chéri compte bond soudain
plein de gens qui lisent jean marie
bigard on t'a reconnu c'est merci voit
dans tout cas d'être là et puis c'est
que je suis très content de te voir
aussi et il ya laurent alexandre
chirurgien et essayiste alors à laurent
alexandre c'est une pointure donc il va
nous éclairer aussi sur ce sujet merci
selon alexandre s'était vu un zoom et
vous êtes beaucoup mieux en vrai merci
est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya une
justice vous johan entre paris et
dunkerque par exemple pourquoi on a
voilà dunkerque vous être confinés et
nous on acquiert que les fans les autres
français calais voilà tout ça ouais
ouais l'autre françois on comprend pas
trop parce que je veux dire chez nous
aussi bien le restaurateur fin tout le
monde tout le monde râle tout le monde
ne tourne était prêt au vin certains
restaurateurs des amis qui étaient prêts
à ouvrir à être hors la loi parce qu'ils
en ont ras-le-bol et c'est
compréhensible pour qu'au paris on n'est
pas confiné alors que on est à 500 cas
pour 100000 habitants que chez nous on
est à 300 350 kg par habitant
nous sommes six millions dans le pas de
calais fin dans les hauts de france
picardie et nord et pas de calais vous
êtes 12 millions en ile de france
donc vous êtes à peu près à 25000 quatre
couvées de et nous on est à 14 minato
comme ça donc je comprends pas pourquoi
le gouvernement on a un premier ministre
qui s'appelle albert dupontel fait
certainement pareil donc lui je
comprends pas pourquoi il confie à paris
et que nous confirme nous pourquoi
fermer nous faire rentrer à 18 heures je
prends l'exemple tout à fait pareil à
paris c'est différent ça la différence
c'est que là 18h à paris je l'a remarqué
en arrivant il ya personne de rentrer à
paris les personnes de rentrer à rien
tandis que chez nous en province
oui parce que les amendes je peux vous
dire j'ai pris de péage de senlis
ils étaient une trentaine de gendarmes
donc voilà sauf si fort qu'ils calment
un peu là dessus parce qu'on n'est pas
non plus pour parler en affaires il être
ensemble voilà ce que tu vaux sirène
inquiète pas moyen donc pourquoi oui
pourquoi pourquoi nous et pourquoi 18
heures
cours laisse pas les gens au minimum
jusqu'au 20 heures par exemple ils
sortent du boulot à 17h 17h30 18h
peut-être ils ont les gosses en garde à
la crèche maintenant d'inculper les
enfants pour faire une prestation à 18
heures pour récupérer les enfants la
cage et vous avez plus de temps derrière
pour aller chercher je vote repas du
soir vous voilà donc 20 heures ce sera
très bien alors au moins pousser 2h02
alors juste laurent alexandre est ce que
la situation en ile-de-france permis
encore de ne pas faire de confinement le
week end ou de ne pas durcir les mesures
c'est très compliqué compte tenu du
waterloo vaccinale c'est à dire du
retard énorme qu'april europe 1 par
rapport aux pays développés dans la
vaccination et la france
thaksin beaucoup beaucoup plus lentement
que le maroc au chili je parle même pas
d'israël qui a fini le programme de
vaccination donc hong hong et on n'a pas
encore d'immunité collective en europe à
part l'angleterre qui est qui a vacciné
extrêmement rapidement donc les chiffres
vous les connaissez ils sont absolument
apocalyptique en droit vers le passé en
l'europe nemat l'italie s'est pas
beaucoup mieux non mille l'europe l'euro
il ne fait pas mieux que la france
oui c'est l'ensemble de l'europe qui a
raté le programme de vaccination par
rapport à israël qui déconfinement le
ter qui va bientôt des confiner les
etats-unis qui ont réouvert les
restaurants on voit qu'on est dans une
session difficile donc le grave échec
européen sur la vaccination fait qu'on
n'a pas beaucoup de choix
on va devoir re confiné au moins
partiellement en ile-de-france mais bien
sûr qu'on a été injuste et que compte
tenu du poids économique énorme de l'île
de france on a retardé au maximum
l'europe demande week-end en ile de
france alors qu'on a tapé sur les sur
les gens des hauts de france mais il
faut savoir que le confinement est
objectivement moins bien respectés à
paris que dans les villes pauvres du
nord pas calais pour une raison simple
c'est que la haute bourgeoisie
parisienne health la fin qu'on y est
l'amant devra c'est ça
vous êtes acheteur ou avocat d'affaires
une à une une amende de 128 euros
vous en avez rien à [ __ ] quand vous
êtes jorane examens scolaires vote mois
il parlait de paris intra muros il
parlait pas d'une opus et que tu peux
pas bien fine et uniquement paris intra
muros j'ai pas dit ça j'ai pas dit que
c'était simple j'ai dis qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui il ya deux poids deux
mesures et que et bien le nord pas de
calais peau mais moins bien traités que
les élites parisiennes d'armes était je
crois avoir compris que la halle à
l'économie que représentent-ils de
france mais ce à l'échelle nationale et
c'est infiniment plus importante c'est
pas du tout m je crois que c'est pas la
france derrière la pression c'est 30%
c'est dramatique ces cétacés parisien de
considérer que la banlieue parisienne
fin que l'île de france et est riche
c'est d'ailleurs tout le problème de à
mon avis de paris aujourd'hui c'est de
considérer qu'il ya que les habitants de
paris
il ya aussi effectivement on vient de le
dire ma voisine les abitova lyall 93
laissé sur le mondial 95 juste la
question que tout le monde se pose mode
c est ce que parce que il faut répondre
à cette question tous les gens on le
voit sur les réseaux sociaux il dit
voilà ils sont par confiner paris parce
qu'il ya tellement il est l'île de
france est tellement d'enjeux
économiques voilà ils veulent préserver
de mariage que c'est vrai ou pas ou
c'est une légende ça ça fait forcément
partie de données qui ont été prises en
accord et de la même façon que les
données sanitaires
on parlait tout à l'heure du taux
d'incidence en fait y'a pas que le taux
d'incidence qui est pris en compte ya
aussi par exemple le nombre de lits en
réalité ce soir disponible
et quand la décision a été prise de
confiner le week-end dans le nord pas de
calais aujourd'hui ça a évolué mais le
nombre de lits disponibles en ile de
france laissait enfin pas encore
entrevoir à un jeu de me répondre je
vous raconte sans le dire je vois
prendre bientôt mais un chemin quand
même y'a pas de parisianisme honnêtement
de la part du gouvernement et j'entends
on peut faire tous les reproches qu'on
veut je les entends je prête à en
débattre
mais vous pouvez pas dire que jean
castex est mon barisien là dessus je
voudrais pas il y aura deux tu te sens
lésée tu ne dis pas bien sûr bien sûr on
n'a pas de vie des jeunes confirmands 18
heures on peut strictement rien faire
c'est bull et 2
métro et puis michael tu ne rien faire
je fais quoi dans la vie déjà yushu
agents de maîtrise dans une industrie
chimique pour lui dessiner la fare aussi
quand il aimerait bien on n'est pas bien
ce que ça fait de marcher pour nous
c'est vrai il aurait des preneurs ayoun
j'en parlerai à mon pdg johann et tuchan
kenna justice toi parce que j'ai
l'impression que tu le vis comme une
injustice côté c'est une injustice
il a été choisi à calais il sait mort
c'est désert alors que calais et calais
ce qu'on appelle calais nord aussi mais
c'est sa vie c'est ça tout de malades
même si je suis pas ami avec la maire de
calais madame bouchehr la république
ordonne des républicains elle fait
beaucoup de choses pour coller c'est une
belle ville
elle s'est beaucoup de choses mais quand
vous entendez que il ya des personnes
qui disent qu'il ya comme une injustice
mode bridge qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez pas encore une fois est ce que
je disais avant la pause c'est à dire
que quand la décision a été prise il y
avait encore des critères en
ile-de-france qui permettait d'espérer
confine pas c'était pas le cas dans le
nord-pas-de-calais s'est même sac et des
ses décisions qui ont été prises ces
vaccins supplément vous avez des pensées
vous avez dépendra également de tous
vous voyez bien que la situation elle a
évolué je vais vous dire à vous confier
notre copie n'est pas paris je m'en fous
royalement paraître et ça reste délais
de livraison de cette commande de nous
embêter et qu'on nous deux qu'on arrête
ce siècle le week-end et en mai vous
pouvez sortir nous avez une carte de la
république en marche
monsieur comme tel parce qu'il fait rire
tout le monde une face au foie puis tout
gouvernement façon ce gouvernement l'os
est ainsi reconnue tout seul non mais
bon voilà c'est mon opinion il ya trois
yable banon mais après je vais vous dire
un truc le week-end bon dieu foutez nous
la paix et laissez nous parce que c'est
une loi ni qu'il veut des magasins est
sorti ce qu'il veut il veut pas lui il
dit pas moi les autres joueurs qu'ils
soient confinés comme dans je me rends
fédérer confinés sur quoi vous dira tu
t'en fous fait la teuf et l'injustice
qui était posée comme ça ça me serait ce
que je répondais juste modèle à elle a
donné elle a dit que ça avait évolué que
la maintenant les cheveux
monte est ce que les chiffres sur cette
région la région des hautes france
baisse pour savoir si eux vont peut-être
être des conflits parce qu'il ya plein
de régions parce que là on attend va
revenir c'est le modèle parler d'eux
je vous appelle mode alors messieurs les
vues pour chiner si jeune divorcée que
non mais pour revenir sur terre vous
parliez des dix mois je vous dire un
truc c'est facile de dire aujourd'hui
nous on est à 91 93 % de deux lits prix
occitanie mation les hôpitaux des routes
france 1 mais c'est normal c'est normal
avant il y avait 30 lire animations on
les a baissé à 10 on en a retiré 26 est
normal que les les hôpitaux sont bondés
y a pas que ça alors honnêtement
aujourd'hui
enfin je comprends que ce soit difficile
et le couvre-feu il est difficile
honnêtement pour tout le monde vous dit
à paris les gens ils sortent après 18h
tu sois je vous assure que tout le monde
se taille pour rentrer chez lui à 18
heures et quand j'entends des effets
incertains faire du parisianisme à la
haye
anne hidalgo parlons en expliquant qu'à
18h à paris céline yeux de l'aprem comme
si quand moi je rentrais en province
chez mes parents en poitou charentes à
18 heures c'était une susan que dix ans
maintenant que paris soit pas il va
faire la guerre
bon ça aujourd'hui vols paris-san et
paris je m'en fous royalement des
chevaux termine et a de plus en plus de
variantes le nom d'heuliez en réa il y
en a de moins en moins et donc ces
décisions là le président de la
république il les prend pas par plaisir
il les prend pas pour vous embêter il
est prêt pour protéger les français
parce que c'est ça pourrait être de
s'emparer alors il protège bien que
protégé hommes supplémentaires dans
quelques temps parce que la situation en
ile de france n'était pas la même et
c'est pas faut pas jouer une région
contre une l'an je ne joue pas vrai j'en
passe je suis fier de vous dire que
paris qui les confine les confine pas je
m'en fous royalement on s'en fout non
pas de calais troisièmement ils veulent
juste être des confidents on vote de
confiner le week-end point b juste alors
attends tirés des jeux de prendre les
moyens à notre égard a divorcé toi je
vais vous prendre à d'autres exemples
j'ai des amis qui travaillent dans des
boîtes de transport sur calais un plein
environ qui traverse vent d'angleterre
ils sont d'angleterre toute la semaine
j'ai anomique ce pèlerinage qui t'arrive
tu peux me rappelle reynald annales des
mots lembras reynolds équipe et lui fait
l'angleterre depuis
ouais ils traversent tous les jours là
il n'est pas vaccinée comment ça se fait
les anglais à l'angleterre
et parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui il ya eu
des contraintes sur les frontières
effectivement qu'on était mise pour
demander des tests et a aussi des
différences qui ont été faites avec les
personnes trans frontalière qui traverse
il ya trois cent mille personnes qui
partent travailler à l'étranger chaque
jour en france et donc il a bien voulu
fallu aussi cette souplesse là parce que
sinon votre ami et reynald alors
justement est bon il n'y aurait pas eu
ça on aurait fermé comme un bloc et soit
devenu un mode de fêtes en achetant
juste de façon il aurait fait là qu'il
aurait été dans les bouchons tous les
matins pendant cinq heures alors juste
une nouvelle rubrique dans cette
émission si vous nous rejoignez à 20h45
un pote une question c'est avec tuyaux
on va partir c'est à dire gg également
les aider non mais ça doit la réponse
mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit non et
parce que maud ne sais pas comment les
la paris elle sait pas comment ça se
passe alors je suis vous dire moi
comment des espaces en angleterre vous
êtes les camions souligné les chauffeurs
sans les nier
et au bout de un mot ils ont amené comme
un compteur à gaz
maintenant soit farid est alors juste
embarras justice mais un autre argument
qui penche en faveur des parisiens des
grandes villes c'est que ceux qui ont le
plus souffert du confinement ce sont les
parisiens et les habitants des grandes
villes à paris à plein d'habitants il ya
plein de personnes qui habitent dans dix
mètres carrés dans quinze mètres carrés
alors que dans les grandes villes en
province et à la cote de maille les gens
habitent dans des maisons dans des
surfaces plus les rôles qu'on veut pas
faire de généralités mais c'est vrai
quand vous habitez dans 12 m² à paris
c'est beaucoup plus difficile quand vous
êtes dans une maison ça c'est non mais
c'est l'argument d'eux mêmes un même
maillot il est non mais la raison le
clac clac évident 10 mètres carrés de
eelv arrête un câble que non en province
rochus elle-même à cauterets n'ont pas
de sujet du terrain géologue chez ing
une cour dont je peux sortir prendre
l'air tout simple quand même pas des
comme vous dites moi ils vont pas dans
l'histoire de la langue parce que le
truc du parisien qui peut payer les
amendes à 130 euros
j'adore ces conscrits non mais oui non
mais c'est pas con mais c'est facile
c'est démago de dire ça oui
ceux qui sont le plus touchés en règle
générale sont les plus pauvres et vous
regardez la seine saint denis
aujourd'hui on est à 4 187 cas par
exemple 1000 habitants et paris arrive
derrière le pas de calais la seine et
marne avec 380 par habitant donc non une
fois de plus ceux qui sont les plus
touchés sont ceux qui ont le moins
d'argent
donc il faut vous pouvez pas vous peut
être pas tenir ce genre de propos c'est
assez marcel rolland alexander je crois
que maintenant font un peu penser à
l'avenir si on veut limiter le
confinement et en sortir le plus vite il
faut qu'on vaccine vite
c'est pour ça que l'arrêt de la
vaccination par la strade n'est qu'un
est catastrophique
vous trouvez que c'est john rice a une
vraie connerie c'est une vraie connerie
fois pas une couille illa kané devant
les allemands vraiment c'est une grave
erreur
chaque jour est de vacciner par l'astre
hazen et cassé 15 morts supplémentaires
en france however axim plus tard il y en
a qui vont mourir parcouraient les axes
et ils ont dit on arrête aussi
l'amérique voit l'allemagne a dit en
premier jamais premier une heure après
c'était tous les pays ont suivi les uns
après les autres
mais pourquoi si l'allemagne est à
quelques mois des élections et la parti
de merkel va extrêmement mal et a peur
de perdre les élections et garcia chair
et d'os gentil vaccin d'accord donc
l'allemagne accablé pour des raisons
politiciennes et macron s'est couché
derrière l'allemagne
résultat des courses l'arrêt de la
vaccination par l'astre à zenica
ça va retarder le déconfinement ça va
retarder la fin des couvre-feux on n'est
pas prêt de réouvrir les restaurants
offrant alors juste selon alexandre la
situation en ile de france et ce qu'elle
permet de continuer comme ça où est-ce
qu'il va y avoir un confinement week-end
comme come on you
on a on a un énorme problème à l'horizon
comprennent pas forcément les gens très
âgés maintenant ils sont vaccinés
même si la france a très peu vaccinés
par rapport aux au pays comparé à mai
les très âgés les gens n'aient pas
disons beaucoup été vaccinées donc on a
une baisse du nombre de morts en ce
moment en revanche on n'a pas vacciner
les gens plus jeunes et les gens plus
jeunes ils font des formes plus grave à
cause du variant britannique c'est ça et
donc on sature l'erea les gens des ehpad
on les a jamais mis en réa donc
l'amélioration de la situation dans les
ehpad
elle n'entraîne pas une amélioration
dans l'airé à parce que de toute façon
les vieux en ehpad ne sont jamais
angèle pour y apposer donc on est dans
une situation dans les semaines qui
viennent on va avoir moins deux morts
d'accord pas beaucoup plus de cas mais
d'airé a complètement et bozizé
exactement pourquoi en fait et c'est
triste de le dire mais c'est parce que
les personnes avant âgée qui était en
rien mine de rien avait beaucoup qui est
décédé on les mettait pas en rire on
n'est pas dans n'allait jamais en vrai
ça en est on voilà donc et aujourd'hui
on a plus de jeunes auraient à casey a
longtemps rêvé on a moins deux morts et
des rayons bozizé mais vous pensez alors
lido france filets ce week end ou pas on
peut pas on peut pas savoir
castex allah dit avant-hier on continue
la stran eca et puis quelques heures
après mâcon a dit on arrête la quinzaine
et quart donc c'est imprévisible ont
fait près d'un million et demi ont battu
des records détrônant vont faire quoi d
un million et demi heure non mais alors
là normalement a priori on aurait dit la
ministre à marcq voilà ça va repartir
ça va repartir et ce stade ils l'auront
alexandrie a dit que c'était une
connerie d'avoir arrêté
ouais donc forcément mode on va à votre
avis confinement ce week end passé votre
village là je parle pas à la porte
parole de red bull nico marche je parle
à l'âme idées à berner moi ce que je
vois je mets de côté ma casquette de
porte-parole de l'ars est forte et avant
tout fut scientifique donc je regarde
intrigue les scientifiques à l'intention
est ce que jamais non mais c'est vrai on
est un danger mais ce que j'en avais
tout lisse et moi elle fait pas du
patinage artistique là il ya des taux
d'incidence qu'on vous mentez
des lits en réa qui sont saturés et donc
je pense que les chances pour qu'il y
ait des contraintes supplémentaires
elles sont fort ça paraît très vite déçu
oui ça peut arriver dans les videmment
que ça peut arriver dans les jours à
venir après j'ai pas de boulangerie et
quel type de conflit est ce que c'est un
film entre quel type de contraintes à
l'esa incapable de vous le dire ce que
je pense en revanche c'est que
effectivement il ya une situation qui
s'est aggravée et que le président de la
république il est là pour protéger les
français
les gens du nord paie donc lui en fait
la fin du mois d'avril et 4 lequel du
mois d'avril risque d'être confiné sais
pas du tout ce que je vous ai dit c'est
bien le mettre sa casquette de
porte-parole de la république parce que
je vous ai dit je vous ai dit qu'il y
avait juste une situation on va
consulter le ce est très inquiétante et
que effectivement il y avait des chances
que des décisions soient prises quel
contenu de 377 gens non rapin 3%